but thing is you know we all do other
jobs we remember starting out and lots
of people do the classic catering David
Schwimmer you went one up from waiting
tables you did waiting tables with a
little bit extra I waited tables for a
long time about seven years but my first
gig was as a rollerskating waiter at
this yeah I was good at this really cool
place in Chicago any cool it was it was
called what's called EDD Bewick came out
of this place
player-character yeah I was Romeo I was
Frankie only Romeo roller-skated lasagna
well in Chicago they had rollerskating
all right
so and I was roller skates and and I was
serving all the outdoor tables so there
was a huge parking lot and a pretty wide
sidewalk with tables lined up like
picnic tables where families would come
in and you'd make not very much money
with minimum wage in the States as
you're aware but you made a lot of money
by performing stunts so I would like
line up people's kids and they would
like you no they wouldn't you know Neil
next to each other in a line I could
probably jump over three or four I'm
serious and then I would say hey you
guys want to see it you know the parents
were like yeah go for it
just like I would just take off down the
street and jump all over I mean over
over them and then and then kind of like
skid to a stop and then I'd get you know
all these fancy tips from doing it but
you had to play a character and my
character was like Romeo the romancer
you know he was kind of based a little
on Travolta in you know Greece or
something you know I mean it was a 50s
diner so I had a big pompadour and you
know bigger muscles at the time this
from that time is this when you were
Romeo oh that earring that screams Romy
yeah no but mine never was not as long
as that it was more of a pompadour okay
yeah similar similar embarrassing
[Music]